la photo en elle même n'est pas
intéressante du taux sauf que après
relecture de la photo visiblement
j'avais laissé échapper quelque chose de
mon slip
regardez vous avez ramené une petite
photo oui je vous ai rapporté une petite
photo parce que je fais c'est hot bas
côté je sais pas je vous laisse juge
donc ça c'est ce que vous faites quand
vous allez en vacances mais c'est
beaucoup de sport quand je suis en
vacances j'aime bien les trucs très
sportif très bien approvisionné suffi et
le rêve là là ne bougez pas je vois déjà
le truc regardes tu postale hier sur la
cuisse oui c'est comme ça ça fait une
petite up du pique nique une photo oui
alors je n'ai envoyé deux je ne sais pas
laquelle a été sélectionné c'est un
copain avec mes frères c'est votre frère
très bien dick te manquer derrière et je
vais descendre doucement dans le sud
pour aider justement mon frère et ma
mère qui viennent d'ouvrir leur bar à
jus 100 % bio 100% vegan hobo provence
[Rires]
vous avez qu à faire de la publicité
vous avez pas un cousin qui vend des
voitures alors la photo de france au
vieux vous pouvez la décrire auparavant
ah ben je suis en lorraine ben écoutez
j'ai mené j'ai pas les moyens de maxime
c'est vrai mais bon les belles photos
j'aurais pu vous dire on leur a demandé
de faire une photo un peu des livres
pour nos cd vraies photos vraiment
savoir comment ça va manger très bien
vous avez pris une photo oui jamais une
photo de vacances
oui c'est une photo entre c'est très
important pour moi c'est entre la baule
et saint nazaire et je passe
régulièrement des vacances là bas et
quand je pars en vacances il faut que je
trouve des pierres donc là je suis sur
ma pierre ont créé ma pierre laba viola
maire heureux qu'est ce qu'ils avaient
sur la pierre pour bouffer
[Rires]
verrier pas une fois sûr et vous allez
sur une pierre il ya une succession de
cette pierre et chaque matin je vais
leur parler
tristesse quand qu'est ce qu'on leur dit
aux pierres à ça dépend desquels l'année
dernière la main par exemple est la
dernière alors y avait une pierre qui
s'appelait jean luc je crois que c'est
celle là la potée parce que je lui
parlais de jeu disait jean luc fau guest
my edge se passe bien et tout ça je
parle aux gens j'ai retrouvera jean luc
c'est la pierre quoi alors là vous avez
la photo mais dix minutes après vous
avez une autre photo avec l'ambulance
qui viennent chercher qu'il le ramène
ensemble ils pas ses vacances alors moi
j'ai emmené une photo justement mais
pour me rappeler un petit peu de bon
temps que du bon temps que je passais en
famille à l'époque où on était tous
ensemble avec mes soeurs avec mes
parents voilà c'est juste à l'époque où
j'avais un look de merde voilà
ce qu'était j'étais en crise d'ado je me
cherchais un peu c'est un mobile-home
derrière ouais on partait au camping à
saint tropez quand on était plus jeune
j'avais bien évolué du mobile home à
l'elysée par tour si vos gamins et le
dernier c'est parce que il y à dos et il
y un dos on a dû à la dernière minute
quand il nous a envoyé sa photo
l'emmener dans un banc de montage car
monsieur prendre des photos sur un
bateau jusque là ça ne me surprend c'est
m'expliquer non mais c'est une photo
qu'on a pris c'est dommage de cash
island et la photo en elle même n'est
pas intéressante de taux sauf que après
relecture de la photo visiblement
j'avais laissé échapper quelque chose de
mon slip
à y regarder alors vous verrez pas mais
le smiley alors c'est pas c'est pas sa
vraie télé comme ça c'est un smiley
qu'on a rajouté oui mais effectivement à
elle part alors là nous ne montrons pas
parce que c'est pas l'esprit de
l'émission de rentrée ce sont des choses
maintenant on est passé à totalement
autre chose
[Musique]